authorities now say they'll rely on
toxicology reports to determine how the
granddaughter of Robert F Kennedy died
an autopsy found no trauma to the body
of Saoirse Kennedy Hill the 22 year old
died Thursday after being found
unconscious at the Kennedy compound in
Hyannis Port Massachusetts that is where
grieving relatives have been gathering
and Adriana Diaz is their age van a good
morning good morning Jeff that's right
members of the Kennedy family are waking
up to their first weekend without their
beloved Saoirse her uncle Robert F
Kennedy jr. called her loss a wound too
large to ever heal we saw the family at
the compound yesterday which is just
down the beach from here they are known
for their privacy especially during
times of loss and yesterday they chose
to retreat to the water they spent the
afternoon on a boat we saw them heading
home from the Yacht Club
her mother Courtney in the front had her
arm around Sierra's grandmother Ethel
Ethel who is 91 is Bobby Kennedy's
surviving wife
RFK jr. was also in Hyannis yesterday
with his wife 22 year old Saoirse was
going to be a senior at Boston College
studying communications while in high
school she wrote about her struggles
with depression in college she loved to
volunteer and was vice president of the
College Democrats late yesterday an
official at the at Boston College wrote
a letter to students asking them to keep
the Kennedy family in their prayers and
also offering counseling the letter
ended saying in the remaining days of
summer I hope you will take care of each
other and of yourselves
Michelle Adriana so much tragedy this
family is faced and really truly the
American nation the American people have
faced with them there's many years it's
been awful to watch all of this unfold
and I covered so many stories there at
the compound over the years of both
working here and in local news in Boston
and the Kennedy family often does go to
the water to find that solace in some
sense of peace and recovery in in
horrible moments like this people have
always talked about them it is we we
don't have a royal family that Kennedy
family for so many has seen that way and
to see this tragedy follow them as just
as you said it's just heartbreaking